how's everyone doing this is Steve on
Trobe with Collider and I am super happy
to have director Bill Condon here in the
studio with us see you nice to see you
thank you so much for coming in the
studio every other interview we've done
has been in a hotel row and it's
impressive this place that you've built
it's incredible the team effort good
thank you to everyone who works at
Collider for making something like this
possible right and our great owners
right I want to start by saying how much
I enjoyed this movie great and I want to
commend you new line Warner Brothers
yeah making yes this kind of adult
thriller which is really hard to make
nowadays yeah it's hard to get made yeah
absolutely
and kudos to them for for making it and
for promoting it and really getting
behind it you know I think everyone
there and we all believe that there's a
big underserved audience of grown-ups
who want an entertaining film this is
truly in the Hitchcock tradition so it's
something that that an audience of a
certain age I think understands because
they grow up with it but I have to say I
hope you know it's a movie with older
actors in which there's no talk of being
sick or anybody dying you know or you
know it has none of those tropes of
movies that you know an 80 year old
actor like Ian would typically be and
these are these are characters who are
fully committed to pulling off something
that they would have been doing when
they were you know in the prime of life
you know so I think it has that vitality
that I hope can translate to a you know
an audience beyond just the people who
are you know attractive to these actors
100% and I'll tell you after seeing it I
completely agree and think that the film
does that the thing about this is also
listen everyone loves Helen everyone
loves Ian you've worked with Ian before
yes just a few years ago how is how is
it getting him and this was it as simple
as like a text message being like I have
a project that I think you'd be good in
right you know it's funny because he's
always said just send it to me and I'll
do it you know and then when you
actually do send it to but it takes a
lot of convincing and on this one you
know he said god it is it is the hell of
a part but I could tell he
was a little concerned at the idea of
playing a villain again he'd made a
career you know he's the great
Shakespeare actor it was generation but
many of those parts were villains you
know so he'd made a career up and well
into middle age of indelibly playing
these villains and then you know decided
to become a movie star you really
pursued it and it happened especially
with Lord of the Rings where he's
Gandalf where he's this great twinkly
character who's actually closer to who
he really is
so I think he had a a slight misgiving
about going to the dark side again you
know just for a moment you know I think
it's just that thing of it's more fun to
be beloved you know it's more fun when
you take the curtain call to be you know
cheered instead of being hissed you know
but he got over that again recognizing
what a good part it was and the
possibility to work with Helen again I
was gonna say yeah I mean I understand
his hesitation for the villain thing but
yeah but it's such a good role it is it
really is you know yeah yeah so
obviously you're a screenwriter you're a
very talented screenwriter but you did
not did you rewrite this or you don't
know Jeffrey Hatcher wrote the script
he'd written the script to mr. Holmes
and you know believe me I and the
producer Greg Yolen were heavily
involved in the what feels like a
hundred and sixty-eight drafts of it so
we really got in there with them but no
it's all Jeff Jeffries work he's he's
brilliant and he's really is he's an
incredible Anglophile which it makes it
made him so right for both this and mr.
Holmes you know he just has this this
way of speaking and thinking like a
British person and this is ultimately
you know a movie that we made in England
that is a contemporary English movie
talk a little bit about how did the
script get changed once you have people
like Ian and Helen coming on board and
maybe you're doing a read-through and
you're hearing their voices yeah a few
ways one of them Helen when I first met
her there was a chunk of the script it's
a little hard to talk about because you
know as with all things in this movie
you don't want to give anything away but
at a certain point the movie sort of
refers back to events in the Second
World War and then the novel that had
all been connected to the Holocaust and
it had been bothering me and I couldn't
put my finger on on what what what it
was and when I met with her for the
first time she said you know I love the
script and it is a wonderful
entertainment but don't you think it's
time to stop using the Holocaust in this
context you know in other words it
wasn't something that was attempting to
you know China new light on what
happened in the Holocaust you know and I
thought it was an exactly right point
you know so we shifted that into you
know again without giving away any
specifics what it was like to be a
survivor of that war as a German who had
to live through both the end of the war
and the arrival of the Russians and the
deprivation that followed which closely
mirrored Helens life because she grew up
I mean she was born just before the war
ended and grew up in a London that was a
life of complete deprivation so it was a
great single note and it made a great
contribution to the script Ian
throughout both of them you know they're
both so smart you know and Ian loves a
puzzle so the that was the reason for
all the you know the the the rewrites
because it is so intricate and so
carefully built you know that you'd
always find somebody who'd say but what
about that's like oh god we didn't think
of that you know and Ian had had a few
of them you know so he was very helpful
you know I think that that's great
because one of the things I thought that
I really enjoyed about the movie is it
all made sense and it all connected and
yeah those those people bringing up the
but what about yeah yeah you know your
if you can fix those things that are
leaking water yep makes that the film
does and to that point you know that was
a thing Helen was really game for this
there are some things you just don't
know right you know you just don't know
how much the audience should know at a
certain point until you put it together
so she was always saying you know we'd
had a discussion early on said hey bill
do you think I should do one where I
just give a little more of it away here
and and she would do it you know
and we actually shot a few scenes where
we revealed one of the twists somewhat
earlier just thinking maybe the audience
would be ahead of us and we had to do
that earlier and so that was a great
luxury in editing you know which as you
know is the last chance to write
something but where we we could put it
all together put it in front of people
and finally figure out really fine-tune
it to figure out how we could lead the
audience through this intricate story
well you bring up editing and I was
gonna get there anyway but this is one
of those films where I would imagine you
do have to test it and show it to people
to figure out like how much information
are you giving out at a certain point
exactly
when is the audience to a head of the
film that's right all that stuff so how
many like early screenings did you do
and what did you learn I do a lot of
them with friends I do you know I have
them over into into the you know a room
like this and and sedate people there
and then ask some questions for a
half-hour and did it I have to say even
after we locked the picture I suddenly
had a new take on the opening and I did
it again with a group of 10 friends but
with groups of people we only did two
proper big Erskine oh three actually two
two official and one with a group of
friends you know hundred people or so
the great thing there was when I read
this novel there was one scene where the
twist really is revealed the main twist
is revealed and I remember getting to
that point in the book and thinking I
want to make this movie because I want
to see that scene plate playing from an
audience and last night we did a
screening at the landmark and again it's
the only the fourth time it's I've seen
it with a group of people but each time
there is this visceral kind of reaction
to which is a real treat yeah I didn't
see it with a big room like that I would
imagine yeah I would imagine a place a
certain way uh how long I've asked you
this in the past how long was your first
cut compared to the finish - oh that is
a good question you know I would say two
hours and five and then the movie with
end credits is an hour and forty nine so
that's a lot that's yeah I mean but was
that like 20 minutes I would say sure
but is that like an assembly cutter is
that like a cut you were pretty happy
with no that was an assembly yeah done
it the cut I was happy with probably had
another five minutes in it so well then
well what was the last thing that you
cut out before picture locking well it
was actually this thing that's opening
the we had originally opened with a
series of bad dates for both Ian and
Helen um
which you then realized you know it was
probably a you know a kind of way for
both of them to you know rehearse for
the for the date that they actually had
you know and they were funny you know so
it was really heartbreaking to pull that
out because it did it did by the time
then you see them with each other which
is the first scene in the movie you've
kind of gotten to know them in this very
extreme circumstance of being face to
face with somebody that you hate and
want to get away from you know but it it
it just set the wrong tone I think it
was just a little too too comic for the
movie that followed I totally want to
see the DC you know hopefully when it
comes out on blu-ray are there they are
there I was gonna say that's really
funny like I could imagine both of them
doing that oh yeah they were both great
yeah um how long because obviously this
is not a Marvel movie this is not some
huge budget no how long what kind of
production schedule did you guys well it
was crazy because it was one of those
movies which I think happened it's
happening before but was more extreme
here where in this case again with Ian I
remember on gods and monsters we had to
start shooting on a certain day because
he had a theatrical commitment same
thing happened here so and those things
are great because you put a gun to
people's heads and suddenly people say
yes you know but I cut off a plane in
London and we were shooting seven weeks
later so that that was and I loved it it
was we just hit the ground running and
it's all location as you know I mean
it's all like complicated stuff to find
and then organized and it was it's the
best way of making a movie you know
everybody just like gets in there you
know God Helen was you know honor grip
practically you know she never leaves a
set she's always there trying to help
out but it was one of those sure how
many days did you have to shoot we shot
38 oh that's also not a lot of dumb no
no what was you getting ready to shoot
you got the 38 days
what is the thing or things that you are
most stressed out about before filming
on the first day oh that's a good
question the things that I can talk
about that I was most yeah I don't want
to spoil it exactly there are things
that immediately come to mind you know
what it is it's that thing that happens
and I've done it three times now in
London especially to Americans where you
where you sort of lay out a schedule
based on how you expect to do it and
everybody says that is impossible in
London you won't be able to move from
here to there you won't be able to get
Helen from her trailer to the set in the
time that you think you can shoot
something that everything is so hard
there everybody says and then on the day
it turns out to be so much easier so
they there are no crews that are better
than British crews but there's a kind of
like worrywart
you know like quality to the people in
charge of stuff that that you have to
kind of push through a little bit sure
what is it like actually filming with
the two of them on location because
they're both huge stars and you know
both of them are loved yes so how much
is it did you have like big crowds
watching you know there was some but I
have to say it's really again I think
cuz things shoot in London so much
there's they're sort of a not a blasé
attitude but people let us be Ian makes
a point of taking the bus from where he
lives all the time when he comes into
Soho you know he is somebody who just
lives he thrives like off of the the
idea that he lives like like a typical
Londoner and and is happy to talk to
anybody at all times so I think in a
weird way people are just used to seeing
her around because especially in the
locations we shot in which are right in
town I think he's there all the time you
know I got to tell you if I saw Ian on a
bus I would it would do like a double
take if you know what I mean yeah I mean
that's that's it's crazy but I respect
that I know I know it's me you know
completely talk a little about with the
ending was it always and I don't want to
do spoilers but was it always going you
know there and did you make any changes
at all based on test screenings going
there being I'll take that thing back
and just say how did those early test
screening yes
impact the overall film and did you end
up making any changes with anything in
the ending there was not one change made
in it you know the movie comes to its
climax the story is told and then we
have a little coda you know about two
minutes a minute with him and a minute
with her and it's one thing I really
learned and I learned it from every
woman who was involved in the movie and
you know in the movie in post and in
marketing and everything that I thought
that there was a way not to certainly
redeem the Ian character but to just
show this little bit of sympathy toward
him and so in that last scene where he's
where we see what came of him the first
cut of it was a little bit more not
tender but it suggested that this person
had lived a very sad life and and isn't
that a terrible thing
and women didn't want to know from that
you know it was very clear it really it
was it was the biggest note we got out
of the first test screening and the
biggest change and truly it was a change
of music and about six seconds of
footage but it really did change the
tone of that last scene with him it's so
people don't realize that that little
bit of six seconds of footage and music
can completely alter your take on a
character it's very and a movie yeah yep
yeah however that it I absolutely you
know yeah I'm I'm trying to focus on
that and thinking anyway uh memorable
moments from filming I'm imagining that
there's like a day or two from filming
that you will always remember yeah you
know what it was we again in this tight
schedule somehow we'd wound up because
we had built this house that much of the
movie takes place in we wound up in the
last week having to do the nine page
Helen Mirren speech on one day followed
by the six page
McAuliffe speech on the other day was
crazy it
was so it was I have to say those two
days watching those acting you can't
imagine the stamina the like you know
all the pressure on them they knew there
was no choice I still feel horrible for
having put them in that position but
somehow we wound up there and to watch
them just just do it you know and kind
of absorb the pressure and and and ride
right over it and deliver in a crazy
great way though the power of those
performances on those two days informed
by the extra you know kind of anxiety
about what they had to pull off yeah I
would imagine that first of all I would
have paid to see that just to watch them
work in that kind of a setting but did
you have when you have actors of this
caliber do you have extra people that
want to visit you on set
that's a good question no not really no
I think no you don't have the right I
mean you need exact different friends
and the other business was Taylor
Hackford on the the last day not Helens
day but Ian's day and he was so sweet he
said okay I've spent five minutes on the
set which which is the limit for what
one director should spend another
director set and then he took off but
but no we didn't have people visiting it
was really quiet oh yeah next time you
know make the call exactly just throwing
that out there yes so talk a little
about how is it with getting out there
and promoting are you going all over the
place are you doing what's let's just
yeah you know it's funny because it's
you know well mr. Holmes a few years ago
but you know it used to be that you
would do that kind of landmark theater
tour you know and you'd be it's
Baltimore to Detroit it's like you're
doing Drive you know like radio every
day and stuff like that but this movie
it's it's odd because it's it's made at
a certain scale but Warner's is
releasing it in a completely commercial
way you know so that it isn't quite the
grassroots kind of marketing that I've
been used to for this kind of smaller
movie which is a relief frankly you know
but yeah I think it's mostly this is
really the beginning which widens for
rusty right now because I haven't done
this before yeah your great lucky too
because I haven't camera answers yet
right but we're about to start that
in London it's most of it's happening in
London next week in New York the week
after that yeah I actually told I mean
my parents don't go to the movies that
often and I said to them that this would
be something you would both really enjoy
oh that's great no it's good but I
actually and I feel strongly that like
this is just an underserved audience
yeah you know and also like I ate at a
screening of Official Secrets right and
at the Landmark no less and one of the
things I found was it was packed with an
older audience yeah and they were really
asking intelligent questions yes and
they wanted to go to the movies I know
same thing last night no it's great
yeah I mean so I think that I mean yeah
anyway that that's a whole the only
thing wrong with them is that they take
their time it's like we've got to go out
the first weekend because we live in
that culture in a very totally I mean
it's sort of survival of the fittest and
you sort of got to keep going and and I
think everyone thinks there's plenty of
time to get to it you know but there's
less and less these days yeah there's
something I actually don't think about
but you're right you know it's an older
audience yeah ambos to the theatre a
little bit I want to touch on a few
other things real quick when you made
Beauty and the Beast
yep what was the dream number at
box-office that you were thinking cuz it
ended up at like 1.2 6 billion right
which is pretty big hit yeah so did you
were you secretly hoping my god can we
break a billion or were you like I don't
wasn't really I was he thinking about
that I think it was because you're in
that exclusive club of making a film
that made over a billion dollars and I
think I don't know what the Twilight
movies made but they also did really
well they did yeah the no but I just
wanted it to you know for me the big
secret agenda there honestly was along
with Hitchcock art I grew up like at the
moment when those big roadshow musicals
died and I loved them you know and I was
you know we were all told at that point
you can't have any more of those you
know and to me I was secretly making one
of those movies you know oh not half
musical you know a full-on musical with
13 numbers and I just wanted it to make
its money back honestly and it was then
the most expensive musical ever made you
know thank
you know since then they just keep
costing more and more but so because I
love the johner so much all those movies
kind of carry the home on their
shoulders the burden of the whole you
know genre so just so there I that was
that was my focus that we make sure that
you know it be a success and not one of
those elephantine bombs that I grew up
with you know there was a lot of talk
for a little while that you were
involved with Bride of Frankenstein yes
so what ended up happening with that
well that was a heartbreaker really we
were involved we were prepping we were
deep into it and I have to say the
simplest way to say it is is that I
think the you know the whole the the
mummy and not to say anything against
the movie but the the fact that that
hadn't worked for them and it was the
beginning of this whole reinvention of
their monsters gave him cold feet you
know at the end of the day because David
kept was writing the script I thought it
was unbelievably good and when we we
were on the verge of making a really
beautiful movie I thought so so that was
a shame yeah I'm a fan of David's
writing yeah and can you tease what it
was if you guys ever talked about what
it was gonna be about or well we know
he'd written I mean it was we were
prepping the movie no I mean like I ever
teased of what like what the movie was
gonna be Oh talk to ya
some know you allowed to or no I don't
know if I am honestly because David I
think is still involved in figuring out
like the new approach yeah you know what
I mean I think it's a dick and I was
doing something The Invisible Man
they're doing that right that's the
first one the next one that they finally
are yeah yeah I you know it's
interesting it's like these classic
monsters are so iconic yeah and you know
maybe listen I know a lot of people
think the thing about blue mouse is
they're obviously gonna make it on a
much smaller budget right but maybe and
maybe I'm wrong about this but maybe
that kind of smaller budget which allow
you to make a lot more creative freedom
when I'm not having to spend so much to
make it probably exactly right and
I think to be fair that's probably what
Universal was thinking at that time too
you know that ultimately we were we the
movie that we started was you know
devised as a great big movie and at the
end of the day probably these movies
should be smaller well I mean I just
look at in terms of you know when you
have less money and you're not trying to
aim at four quadrants yeah you know if
you're making something between 20 and
50 million you can do a lot more with
very true you know and really also push
boundaries you know or sure although we
were doing some of that there too sure
yeah but I would have really liked to
have you know yeah you a while ago I
asked you about this and I will get the
update you were linked to this Richard
Pryor project yeah yeah so whatever is
that well that was that when you talk
about you know how hard is get movies
made that I started that like right on
the heels of Dreamgirls like I spent two
years writing that I'm I'm really proud
of that script and it was something that
was a go picture at three different
places three different times with
different casts and then there was
always something that made it fall apart
i alternate Lee had to leave it there
were other I think Lee Daniels was
involved with a lot with it for a long
time and Oprah Winfrey was involved and
that fell apart
Harvey Weinstein fell apart you know so
I don't know where it is what's
interesting I think is that is that I
don't think you know we live in a world
where I could I could direct that movie
anymore frankly you know I do think
that's something that's changed you know
probably for the better in the last 10
years you know that that would need I
think I think the feeling is that that
would need an african-american director
you know I'm I'm thinking I think that
it's I think it would be good for us
someone to an african-american director
or to helmet but I also think that well
anyway it's just one of those projects
that I just can't believe hasn't moved
forward they know who he is I know I
know it's a great project and and
I do think there's some little curse on
it or something because it only the
oddest things always seem to bring it
down you were right you were one of the
people who wrote greatest showmen where
did you a my wrong about this no no no
it's always odd for me I always say I
can't take any credit or blame for that
movie because because I really came in I
was I'm good friends with Larry Marc the
producer and they were I I came in for
eight weeks to kind of just shape it
into a musical you know sure and and
then it was two years before they and I
was shot beating the beast and all that
before they actually shot that movie so
yes it was fun to make that contribution
to it but I don't feel like I have the
right to say I have any real authorship
I completely got it are you were you
surprised I mean cuz it was it ended up
becoming a big hit yeah were you did you
know when you were working on it like oh
this could be some no because it was
when I was working on it there are a
number of composers doing songs and
Pasic and Paul had only done one song
and I think the reason it's a big hit is
first and foremost of them you know that
they they wrote a number of songs that
people fell in love with you know and I
do think if you look at this resurgence
of music driven movies and then the
occasional musical that doesn't work as
well as the others it is as simple as
like do people love the music and want
to just hear it again and again you know
Bohemian Rhapsody right or greatest
showmen as opposed to some of the others
that maybe not as much you know but that
to me no because they weren't kind of
dominant then I didn't really have a
clue you know those songs are very
popular yeah I know I'm almost out of
time with you or out of time no and I
will just say that what no I know so I'm
gonna ask you a few fun questions before
I get the hook from in my shoulder what
TV show would you love to guest write
and direct Oh TV show I gotta say not it
was I'm gonna rephrase the question and
say what TV show would you have loved to
have written or directed got it
something in the past right and that's
years and years which I'm just obsessed
with the Russell T Davies who sure who
did queer as folk and
cucumber banana I think he's just a
genius but but that show as kind of
really really and I gotta say that an
escape from Dannemora both of them are
just I think just incredible
like great arguments for how this forum
is is fantastic when when it's in in
those kind of hands you know like the
the six hour telling a sprawling story
in the case of years and years just like
capturing the the Trump world that we
live in so brilliantly in a way that
made you not be able to sleep at night I
thought it was incredible um do you what
movie have you seen the most oh that's a
good question I would have said vertigo
honestly or favorite ride at Disneyland
see you get me in trouble because I went
to Disneyland once when I moved here and
I never went back so say no more okay is
there anything that you collect do ya
blu-rays and DVDs do you have more than
five thousand I do really I just spoke
to bond for parasite and he says he has
five thousand right that's what he
collects as well yeah do you what do you
have a number it's well I have places in
New York and LA I got it you basically
have an unhealthy collection exact but
by the way there's nothing wrong with
this I think a lot of people wish they
had that many movies was the last thing
that you really were obsessed with oh I
remain obsessed with it really honestly
the Trump story you know the the the the
end of Donald Trump you know that's yeah
I don't want to get you in trouble I
will just say hopefully soon um what uh
what TV show have you watched all the
way through more than once I think none
honestly that's and that's my biggest
argument against you know this eternal
argument movies against TV you know I do
think the to our form is something that
from the beginning of time practically
you know drama was something you spent
an evening doing that sixties you know
Jersey and there's there I mean you know
Sopranos being still the greatest
example and I know people live while
like but I don't I feel like the the
time you spend living in that world when
you complete that it feels completed and
it feels I don't know it feels daunting
to take up all of the to realize you'd
have to go through all the episodes it
didn't work or the ones that stretched
and all that stuff you know do you own
any movie or TV show props I don't put
my partner it has quite a few what film
scared you as a kid yes as I said your
window like crazy psycho of course and I
did see all these things but the first
one I saw in a movie theater and it was
on the night that we moved into from an
apartment into a house and I had my own
room for the first time I think it was
five and it was a tiny room but with a
radiator that made clicking noises that
I didn't understand so I thought it was
somebody knocking on the window and I
just seen the Vincent Price movie you
know the one where he has the bat of oh
god I think we can just add to Vincent
Vincent Price Mel Bates
it's not oh man we have to look it up
but anyway he's got a vat of acid in the
basement he you know throws bodies in
there I saw this if I the hunting of
Hill House no it's not bad it yes that
was the oh man yeah but you saw this at
five years old
ambien this week yeah the I did I did
yeah Wow
yeah but that's early it is it is yeah I
think that could explain a lot I know I
love far I loved far from the beginning
um my last thing for you do you remember
what it was as a kid that made you fall
in love with movies or say I wanted to
go do that yeah that's a good question I
think you know I got a super8 camera as
a present again when I was like seven or
something like that and I started I
think it's a way I think if you feel the
least bit alienated from your life or
find yourself more an observer than a
participant having a camera is the
greatest greatest way to
to be like I don't know accept that
about yourself you know and turn it into
something so for me families were about
filming things and funny things and then
having my little splicer and editing and
showing it and things like that so I
think it was actually the that you know
the camera sure
on that note I'm just gonna say at the
end of the interview here
happy birthday bill oh thank you thank
you and that's enough of that right I
just want to point out he came in on his
birthday which is awesome good lawyer is
fantastic okay I hope it's a big hit for
you and I do think that as we've talked
about this is a movie aimed at an
audience that's really underserved but I
do think it's it's better than just it's
just for an older audience yeah it's a
really good thriller yeah you know yeah
on that note thank you so much for
coming thank you it's a pleasure